I got to work with Steve Martin I didn't
care yeah he was great you know I got to
make him laugh and he made me laugh and
I learned from him one thing was cool
was watching Steve Martin at the end of
every take going to the Monitor and
going oh yeah I can go bigger there I
can do this oh yeah and like watching
what he do were a lot of actors like no
just you know I don't want to see the
monitor I don't want I think it's
different with drama you don't want to
go watch yourself like on you know but
how do you feel about that are you sort
of removed from that like I don't need
to see it as good it depends it depends
uh
definitely if I'm into the thing that I
did I want to see it but I didn't I
don't I've watched out of 280 something
episodes of Hawaii Five-O I've watched
maybe four of them
and I just did a season of a show 10
episodes I haven't seen a frame